is still a huge amount that we do not
yet know about the variant
the number of mutations that it has and
the nature of these and some of the very
early indications from southern africa
have raised the concern that this
variant might be more transmissible than
delta which of course is currently the
dominant variant in scotland and many
other countries
however much more data and analysis is
required to be certain of this and if it
is more transmissible to understand by
how much
further work is also needed to confirm
what impact this variant might have on
the effectiveness of vaccines and the
risk of re-infection the wh show said
yesterday that preliminary evidence
suggests there might be an increased
risk of reinfection but stress that
information at this stage is still
limited
it also said that there is currently no
information to suggest that the symptoms
for from omicron are any different to
the symptoms from other variants in
other words although again more data is
still required there is no evidence at
this stage to suggest that the disease
caused by omicron is more severe
now the days and weeks ahead will tell
all of us much more about the nature of
this variant and therefore its
implications if there are implications
for our response to the pandemic
what we do know at this stage though
confirms in my view that we should treat
it seriously and that we should continue
to act on a precautionary basis at this
stage while we all hope that the
emerging understanding of it will reduce
rather than increase our level of
concern there is no doubt that this
presents potentially the most
challenging development in the course of
the pandemic for quite some time
let me turn now to the situation in
scotland we have stepped up our
surveillance in recent days and i want
to thank public health teams for the
work they are doing to ensure that we
are able to detect cases of this variant
quickly
as we confirmed earlier today that
enhanced surveillance has identified six
cases of the omicron variant in scotland
so far four of these are in lanarkshire
and two in greater glasgow and clyde now
it's important for me to stress that the
contact tracing of these cases is still
ongoing however at this stage we know
that not all of them have any recent
travel history two or known links with
others who have traveled to the
countries in southern africa where the
variant was originally detected
this suggests that there might already
be some community transmission of this
variant in scotland but again let me
stress there is no evidence yet that
this is sustained nor any evidence from
the enhanced surveillance that it is
widespread at this stage
however evidence of even limited
community transmission underlines the
importance of all of us increasing our
compliance with the protections that are
in place
and i'll turn now to the actions we have
taken we have already reintroduced some
travel restrictions even with evidence
of community transmission locally these
travel measures are important and i'll
see more about them shortly but given
that omicron is already present in
scotland we also need to consider
carefully what steps are necessary and
proportionate to reduce transmission
here
some protections that the uk government
has announced in recent days in relation
to england for example the requirement
to where face coverings in some settings
are of course already in place and in
fact more extensive already here in
scotland so at this stage we are asking
people everybody across the country to
significantly step up and increase
compliance with all existing precautions
face coverings hygiene like washing
hands and surfaces
getting vaccinated and of course testing
your cells regularly with lateral flow
devices and
for from now on testing yourself before
mixing socially with people from other
households
we're also reminding people to work from
home if possible as of today i'm asking
employers to ensure that they are
maximizing the potential of homework
however
this may be and is likely to be a
fast-moving situation so our response
will be kept under close review as we
learn more about the risk omicron poses
and the nature of transmission here in
scotland
a key part of our initial response will
be to continue to identify cases as
quickly as we can and where possible
after that break the chains of
transmission and to that end additional
testing will be undertaken in areas
where cases have been identified
now our local response will complement
the uk wide travel restrictions that aim
to avoid importing new cases where we're
trying to curb community transmission
even with cases already here it is
really important to do what we can to
prevent new seeding of the variant from
elsewhere so in line with the rest of
the uk we have reinstated the red list
of countries and to date 10 countries
from southern africa have been added to
that red list anybody traveling back to
scotland from those 10 countries must
enter manage quarantine for 10 days on
their arrival
in addition anyone arriving in scotland
from anywhere outside the common travel
area will be asked to take a pcr test on
the second day after arrival and
self-isolate until they get the result
of that test
we know however that the incubation
period for this virus is very often more
than two days so our view is that it
would be sensible on a precautionary
basis for these travel rules to be
tightened further that's a view shared
by the welsh government i had a call
yesterday with first minister mark
drakeford and he and i have written this
morning a joint letter to the prime
minister
we're proposing a tougher four nations
approach to travel restrictions at this
stage they would see people arriving in
the uk from overseas as to self-isolate
for eight days under our proposal they
would take a pcr test on day eight of
their arrival as well as on day two we
believe this measure would be more
effective in identifying cases of this
variant which result from overseas
travel and therefore help us prevent
further community transmission from
imported cases
now as we know from earlier stages of
the pandemic with so many people
traveling to scotland and indeed to
wales via airports in england anything
less than a four nations approach to
requirements like this will be
ineffective so we hope that a four
nations agreement can be reached
a four nations approach obviously
requires the four nations to discuss
these issues together and hear the best
advice available so mark drakeford and i
have also called on the prime minister
today to immediately convene a cobra
meeting with representation from each
nation to discuss what additional steps
we might have to consider and how we
work together to tackle at this new risk
mark rightford and i are also conscious
of the very real concerned businesses
and staff will feel at the possibility
of further protections becoming
necessary now let me stress we all hope
this will not be necessary but it is
prudent to plan ahead and so we have
also thought confirmation that should
any further protections be necessary
treasury funding will be available to
any of the four nations that require to
activate business support schemes
now given the serious tone and content
of my statement today i want to stress
this
it is always important and we've learned
this over these past two years in the
face of new developments in this virus
to prepare for the worst to act on a
precautionary basis but that
does not mean
that we are not hoping because we are
hoping for something considerably short
of the worst we are still hoping for the
best and hoping that our developing
understanding of this variant will
reduce rather than increase our concern
i very much hope that additional
protections can be avoided and while we
will act on a precautionary basis we
will also seek to act at all times in a
proportionate manner
i want to end by stressing at what we
can all do vaccination remains our most
important line of defense
we had
already outlined last week that the
scottish government was working to
accelerate even further the booster
vaccine program
we will now step up those efforts even
more we are expecting a statement later
today from the jcvi confirming its
updated advice on vaccination the
scottish government is getting ready to
operationalize any new recommendations
from the jcvi for example in relation to
the interval between second doses and
boosters or the range of people who can
now receive booster jacks and we will do
that as quickly as is possible
vaccines do remain our best line of
defence and i want to stress at this
point
if and it is still an if vaccines do
prove to be less effective against this
new variant
vaccination will still be hugely
important less effective does not mean
ineffective if anything the new variant
makes it more important not less
important to get all doses of the
vaccine over the weekend 40 to 49 year
olds became able to book boosters
through nhs in form older age groups can
already do so so if you're 40 or over go
to the website book a booster for when
you are due it and if you haven't yet
had your first or second doses please
book an appointment to get them now
the scottish government will
consider carefully in the coming days
any further actions that are necessary
as we get more information about this
variant and the extent of its presence
here but the point i want to end on and
indeed stress at this stage is that the
same measures that have worked against
previous strains of this virus will also
help us curb any transmission of this
new variant so if in recent weeks you've
been sticking a bit less rigorously to
all of the public health advice which i
think is entirely understandable and i'm
sure we are all in that position to a
greater or lesser extent
now is the time to start following all
of that advice vigorously again every
one of us can make a difference in
protecting ourselves and each other so
let me just end with a reminder of what
all of us can do and what it is really
important that all of us do
do at this stage these steps are now
vital so i'm asking everybody not to see
this as optional firstly get vaccinated
it is the single most important thing we
can do to protect ourselves and each
other
secondly test for covid regularly as i
said we will be increasing testing in
areas where the new variant has been
identified but for all of us wherever we
are even if we're feeling fine regular
lateral flow testing is a really
important way of finding out if we might
have the virus so on any occasion that
you're intending to socialize or mix
with people from other households
whether that's in a pub a restaurant a
house or even a shopping centre please
do an lfd test you can get kits online
or pick them up from local pharmacies or
test centers they are free so get as
many as you need and keep your supply
topped up and finally comply
with all of the existing protections
where face coverings on public transport
in shops and whenever you're moving
about in hospitality settings keep
windows open if you have people in your
house to improve ventilation because we
know that helps follow all of the advice
on hygiene it's time to go back
rigorously to washing our hands to
cleaning surfaces and as i said earlier
please work from home right now if you
can
the economy secretary will be meeting
business organizations later this
afternoon and stressing that homeworking
when possible will help us get through
the winter and also this latest risk
more safely
the discovery of this new variant makes
these measures more important than ever
before they will make a difference and
by sticking to them we will give
ourselves the best possible chance of
enjoying the more normal christmas we
are all looking forward to but enjoying
not just a more normal christmas but a
safer christmas too and hopefully of
avoiding the need for any tighter
protections in the weeks to come
so please let all of us make sure that
we up our compliance right now this of
course is a concerning development but
if we take it as a reminder not to let
our guard slip then i hope we can
protect the stronger position that we
had already got ourselves into so please
get vaccinated test yourself regularly
and follow all of the protections that
are in place thank you to everybody for
doing all of these things and for what i
know everybody will be seeking to do in
the weeks ahead